we've all lost bad games that that that
goes without a saying but I'm trying to
think of a Wesley so game where he's
lost nonone come to mind right it's and
look at the pr clearly looking queen7
and there you have it look at the the
Precision on that man give me that
exchange on
B8 which I will happily capture with
check oh and uh let's go Wesley a quick
Shake of the head he didn't see an
answer to Queen C7 he resigned and uh
well there we see Fabiana Carana winning
in how many moves 94 I
think moves sorry what a game there from
Fabiana Carana what a disappointment
from wesy it just went wrong from the
opening and one big mistake just set off
a catalyst for more bad decisions